[Music]
there's something wrong with the
school something doesn't feel
[Music]
right Sophie what
happened I think there's someone
here that's not meant to
be what did you
[Applause]
see I saw
none
what is she
doing she's standing in
her this thing has come back for
me this demon was once an
angel rejected by
God stripped of
power
it wants that power
back it's okay to be
scared I'm scared
too you send that thing back to
[Music]
hell
tonight we are all afraid there have
been two
murders inite Haunting in Venice we take
the bones of Agatha Christie's mystery
the book called Halloween party and put
it into Venice with all of these
wonderful actors to create the perfect
haunting
mystery it was very exciting to be a
part of this ongoing film Legacy of
these
stories and action my character is
Loosely based on Agatha Christie horo
I've found something she's a
spiritualist come with me to the
Halloween party we're invited to a
s it's a treat to be in the Agatha
Christi world and everyone's really
supportive and we all come together and
the cameras are all up I love that I
love the theatrical side of it in doing
the schemes can rot everyone together as
an ensemble is very collaborative the
whole group had to be very dramatic with
different nuances is someone
there
Mur what is
happening
with Ken directing it's very good we get
everyone together and we all just talk
these team bonding exercises and just
creates this real sense of a unit and a
company of actors and we're all in this
together this is the beauty of having a
big Ensemble just have this connection
and this shared
experience if I'm tra here so are
you all of these wonderful actors
provide a Humanity that is very very
touching and very
haunting all of which confuses you and
you are in quite the conundrum as to who
done it for once in your life admit that
you are up against something bigger than
[Music]
you directed by Kenneth
Brana when the war
started they protected me
took better care of me than humans would
have they not people
Maya it's just
programming 10 years ago today the
artificial intelligence created to
protect us detonated a nuclear warhead
in Los
Angeles this is a fight for our very
existence Sergeant Taylor we are this
close to winning the war
but the AI are developing a super
weapon retrieve
it or they
wi did you locate the weapon yeah it's
just a
kit are you going to heaven
no you got to be a good person to go to
heaven
then we're the same we can't go to
heaven cuz you're not
good and I'm not a
person do you have any idea what that
thing is she looks like a little girl
now but she's
growing Whoever has that kid wins the
war who side you want
huh the End come back to
you what do you want sweetie for robots
to be
free oh we don't have that in the fridge
how about ice
cream
Dre
of all the men to cheat you pick John
Kramer the cancer is still spreading I'm
afraid there's nothing else we can do
there is one person who might be able to
help our program is a two-prong
treatment outside Mexico City the
results have been stunning she saved my
[Music]
life you're in very good hands with
us after that what happens then your
whole life happens then John
Kramer according to these
scans the tumor was never removed
how much time do I have months at best I
still have a lot of work that needs to
be
done hello everyone it's time to play a
game
you all pretended to cure me but what I
have planned for each of you is very
real Came Upon
Me No
Light No sound the only thing I have not
provided is your anesthetic but trust
me you will want to remain
[Music]
alert of all the men to cheat you pick
John crram please don't
hesitate place a big enough piece of
your cerebral tissue into the glass
enzyme tank this will save your
life
this is not retribution it's a
Reawakening all
[Music]
the live or dark the choice is
yours
don't be
scared we've met
before are you looking for Reagan are
you looking for
Reagan he RS in
H
what do you think evil
is I'll tell you what I think it
is we're born in this world with Hope
and
Dreams and a desire to be happy
Dad something's going on with my
daughter no no
it's happening to my daughter too the
devil has one wish Wherever those girls
went they brought something back with
them to make us lose faith I believe you
can help get our daughters back to kill
it in us and the devil never gives
up she knows who I
am where's the other
girl she is waiting here
what you're doing here is dangerous
people have died on both sides of
possession come on baby come back to us
okay if you don't make it I don't make
it mama what is it baby I can't can't
see you baby I'm right here I don't want
to go to
hell God play that trick on
you
they're two heartbeats is it working
they're beating in
sync be
strong what did you
do one girl lives one girl dies you get
[Music]
[Applause]
choose
[Music]
a
I have a job for you piece of cake
really give me your
head it's a security
gig
hello welcome to Freddy's have you met
the them
yet me
who
foxy Bonnie Chica and
Freddy back in
the80s some kids went missing what is
this it's why the place shut
down the police searched Freddies hey
they never found the
kid on the heck
[Music]
ghost
children possessing giant
robots tell me how to stop
them you
don't it's too
late he's
[Music]
coming